[Applaus]
in Kürze fährt der Kommandant der
vierten Panzergrenadierbrigade
Bundespräsidenten Professor Alexander
van der Bellen dem Beginn der
ausrüstungsparade zu melden ihm folgt
ein weiterer Ulan mit der Standarte der
vierten dahinter sehen Sie die
Standarten bzw Fahnen der Verbände der
vierten Panzergrenadierbrigade nämlich
auf einer Panzerhaubitze M109 die
Standarte des aufklärungs- und
arteriepartements 4 danach auf einem
Kampfpanzer Leopard 2 die Standarte des
panzerbataons 14 gefolgt von zwei
Schützenpanzern zuerst die Standarte des
panzerkandidierungs 13 dann die
Standarte Distanz 35 aus großmittel und
abschließend die fahndistanz
Fahrzeug Bingo voraus der Keil bzw
Staffel der Militär Polizei
ich melde die Parade in der Gesamtstärke
von 980 Soldaten und 190 Fahrzeuge davon
88 gepanzerte kamerze 22 Luftfahrzeuge
bereitschaftnahme
jawohl mit der Parade beginnen
wir kommen nun zum lufttreffpunkt in
Kürze sehen Sie einen gemischten Verband
bestehend aus folgenden Luftfahrzeugen
vier aluett 3 4 oder 58 kaiwa zwei
agustavel 212 2 S70 Black Hawk besonders
heute zum ersten Mal präsentiert der
Leonardo AVI 169 4 PC-6 Pilatus Porta 4
PC-7 Pilatus Turbo Trainer und den
Abschluss des luftbetreffens bilden 2 €
Fighter Taifun die Hubschrauber dienen
zum Transport für Rettungseinsätze zur
grenzraumüberwachung mit spezieller
Ausrüstung für Nachteinsätze und können
mit ausnahmetalle mit drei auch leicht
bewaffnet eingesetzt werden heuer
erstmals
Hubschrauber Leonardo aw169 es ist ein
Hubschrauber der 5 tonnenklasse der von
zwei Triebwerken mit die 1.100 PS
angetrieben wird damit erreicht eine
Höchstgeschwindigkeit von 270 km/h und
kann über 800 km weit fliegen die
Nutzlast des Hubschraubers beträgt bis
zu 2 Tonnen und es können bis zu 12
Personen transportiert werden 24
Maschinen werden als Schul- und
einsatzhubschrauber in einen
lebensstationiert und 12 in eigenem
das Flächenflugzeug Pilatus Porta
übernimmt kleinere Transportaufgaben
sowie den Transport von falsch
entspringen die PC-7 dient als
Schulungsflugzeug für die
schulgrundausbildung
[Musik]
hinter den Rettungsfahrzeugen folgt ein
geschützter Jägerzug dieser wird mit
Masse mit zwei Mannschaft
transportpanzern
hier dargestellt in Weiß und Grün
geführt
dieser 448 PS starke Motor bringt das
18,5 Tonnen schwere Fahrzeug auf eine
maximale Geschwindigkeit von 118
Stundenkilometer
in Straß in der Steiermark stationiert
hinter diesen geschützten Fahrzeugen
folgt ein Fahrzeug mit Drohnen diese
sind auch im österreichischen Bundesheer
vertreten und es ist dies die Drohne
Trecker die auf einem Lastkraftwagen der
Firma man aufgebaut ist diese Drohne
[Musik]
anschließend folgen die Neuerungen der
versorgungselemente dargestellt durch
das Leiste bergefahrzeugrad mit
telenladeanhänger beladen mit einem
Pandur Evolution weiters durch das
mittlere bergefahrzeugrad und dem
geschützten schweren Bergefahrzeug HX
[Musik]
das Jägerbataillon 17 ist dann der
Erzherzog johann-kaserne in Strass in
der Steiermark beheimatet dieses
Bataillon ist das Kompetenzzentrum
Pandur Evolution im österreichischen
Bundesheer und zählt mit seinen
gefechtsfahrzeugen zur gehärteten
Infanterie
in weiterer Folge sehen Sie in diesem
Modul einen Aufklärungszug auf alle
schutzfahrzeug Gingo dahinter einen
Aufklärungszug auf geschützten
mehrzweckfahrzeugen Husar drei
geschützte jägerzüge auf Pandur
Evolution einen geschützten Jägerzug auf
universalfahrzeug-
ein ABC abwehrzug mit dem
dekontaminationssystem Mammut ein
pflegeabwehrzug mit einem feuerleitradar
zwei Flieger
und abschließend einen
versorgungselement bestehend aus zwei
sanitätsfahrzeugen einen
werkstattfahrzeug und einem schweren
Bergefahrzeug
[Musik]
auch einige Worte zum
bvs-10 hecklungs insgesamt hat ein
Gesamtgewicht von 16 Tonnen eine
Besatzung ein Fahrer und maximal 10
Personen die aufgesessen mitfahren
können die Motorleistung liegt bei 285
PS mit einer Höchstgeschwindigkeit von
65 Stundenkilometern oder einer
Bewaffnung
12,57 mm überqueren Maschinen
dahinter folgen
mit einer Höchstgeschwindigkeit von 120
Stundenkilometern
einen Allradantrieb und einer
Motorleistung von 89 PS
im Anschluss daran sehen Sie ein Element
der Militärpolizei hier am Beginn einen
Husar hergestellt durch die Firma Iveco
Italien
Kampfgewicht 7500 Kilogramm und 150 kW
oder 190 PS
die weißen Fahrzeuge Toyota LC 200
dahinter ein VW Bus T6 der
Militärpolizei
es folgen Fahrzeuge mit den
hundeanhängern
die jeweils Platz für zwei militärhunde
bieten
und den Abschluss machen zwei Fahrzeuge
im nächsten Block sehen Sie einen
Nachschub und Transportzug
nach dem Anschluss Transportfahrzeug ein
geschütztes
hakenladesystem mit trinkwasseraufsatz
im Anschluss daran
ein pionierkampf-
Terminen
[Musik]
manipulationsfahrzeug Theodor
es folgt ein ABC Abwehr Element dieser
abc-abwehrzug besteht aus ABC abwehr-
einem
Tanklöschfahrzeug 4000
anschließend das
decodermentationssystem Mammut
im nächsten Malblock ist ein Flieger
am Beginn ein Radarsystem skyguard
anschließend Zwillings
fliegerabwehrkanone 35 mm
auf dem Pinzgauern eine leichte
fliegeraffe Mistral
und anschließend ein Zielzuweisung und
aufklärungsrader
den Abschluss bildet hier ein
versorgungselement mit Sanitäts
anschließend einem qualitätspandur einen
Werkstatt Ingo und dem schweren
Bergefahrzeug dass wir heute bereits
einmal gesehen haben
wir kommen nun zum im wahrsten Sinne des
Wortes die in schweren Kräften das
sogenannte mächtreffen das mächtreffen
der vierten panzergrenadre wird den
kommenden
35 Oberst Michael Lex aufgesessen auf
einem Schützenpanzer Ulan und der
Standarte geführt es folgen die dritte
panzergrenadiert Kompanie mit drei
grenadierzügen davon zwei aus großmittel
und ein Ausritt im Innkreis für das
Gefecht sowohl auf als auch abgesessen
die erste panzerkomponie des Panzer war
für uns 14 auf Kampfpanzer Leopard 2 A4
als Hauptträger des Kampfes im
panzergelände einer panzerbatterie auf
1909 davon voraus drei rechenstellen und
sechs Geschütze ein Tuning Kampf
unterstützungselement dargestellt durch
einen pionierpanzer auf tieflandesystem
30 Tonnen beendet wird das Modul durch
die verseinheiten der Brigade welche
sich in diesem Fall aus einem
Bergepanzer M88
einem sandpanzer Ulan einen
Bergefahrzeug der gepanzer Greif A1 und
dem neuen
schwerlasttransportsystem 70 Tonnen
welches eine Kampfpanzer Leopard 2 A4
transportiert zusammensetzt
[Musik]
nach dem mächtreffen folgt als nächstes
das Treffen der Spezialeinsatzkräfte
[Musik]
die beiden Fahrzeuge nach dem
kampfelement zeigen Soldaten vorbereitet
für den taktischen Fallschirmsprung aus
großer Höhe mit sauerstoffausrüstung am
Anhänger sehen Sie vorbereitete
ultra-abwurf um die Mobilität am Boden
zu verbessern
[Musik]
diese Quads und die Motorräder werden
taktisch als hochmobile
Gefechtsfahrzeuge zum verbringen von
Trupps mit speziellen Fähigkeiten wie
Scharfschützen als Flankensicherung oder
jointactical Air Controller zur Leitung
der Feuerunterstützung der am Boden
eingesetzten Truppe aus der Luft oder
mit Artillerie verwendet
im Anschluss daran sehen Sie ein
kampfelement in der zweiten Hauptaufgabe
der Spezialeinsatzkräfte dem Kommando
Unternehmen ebenfalls mit zwei
Handwerkern
wollen unmittelbare Unterstützungskräfte
auf All Terrain
einen hundeführer-
Kommandos hier zur Unterstützung eines
kommandounternehmens sowie ihre
Spezialfahrzeuge ein sido sowie ein
leichtes Boot der Spezial Einsatzkräfte
um auch am Wasser hochmobil sein zu
können
Soldaten ist ja Kommandos sie ist
speziell ausgebildete und ausgerüstet
sie erfüllen besondere Aufgaben und der
Höchster körperlicher geistiger
Belastung sie engagieren unter schwierig
sie agieren unter schwierigsten Gelände
und Witterungsbedingungen sowie extremen
Gefahrensituationen und klimatischen
Bedingungen
weiterwirken Evakuierungen im Ausland
gewährleisten Jagdkommando Soldaten die
Sicherheit unserer Staatsbürger wie zum
Beispiel in Ägypten Libyen Afghanistan
und zuletzt in der Ukraine
Abwechslung Herausforderung und Elite
sind drei Schlagworte die für die
Erwartungshaltung des Jagdkommando
stehen nun kam Retro niemals zurück ist
der Leitspruch des ja Kommandos
begrüßen Sie bitte wir haben kräftigen
Applaus das fußtreffen der heurigen
Ausmusterung
[Applaus]
[Musik]
meine Damen und Herren bitte halten Sie
die Straße frei da Kommandant wird sich
dann abmelden es fährt noch ein Panzer
bitte machen Sie die Straße frei danke
sehr
[Applaus]
meine Damen und Herren ich wiederhole
machen Sie bitte die Straße frei es
fährt noch ein Panzer
[Musik]
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren zum
Abschluss erfolgt noch einmal die
Meldung der Beendigung
2023 einen Bundespräsidenten
Universitätsprofessor Dr Alex
durch den Parade Kommandanten
brigadirmagist
ich ersuche Sie die Fahrbahn frei zu
machen denn es kommt noch einmal ein
Panzer auf der Straße
die Beendigung der Parade und bitte um
weitere Befehle
jawohl abrücken
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das privilegierte und uniformierte
bewaffnete Bürgerstadt Wiener Neustadt
wird es Aufstellung beziehen auf der
Grazer Straße in Kürze mit der
Kommandant den Bundespräsidenten melden
und einen salut abfeuern die Geschichte
ist untrennbar mit der Stadt verbunden
und wurde ihnen ja bereits zu Beginn der
Parade näher gebracht
[Musik]